this is a production of Cornell
University um so yeah hi everyone I'm
Pete Selby um I am the brappy project
coordinator um and the team of one on
the brappy project officially um and I'm
here to talk about the brappy project um
as well as you know little bit the
broader scope of um system integration
and and interoperability so um yeah
we'll we'll start we'll start there um
so you know there's lots of different
ways to connect systems to make they
make sure they work together um and I
see you know one one axis of this is is
on a scale of uh automation like how how
automatically do systems connect to each
other and are are interoperable between
each other and so on one side you've got
you know flat files or paper files that
you're sharing with each other and and
you know sharing data between different
organizations and different systems on
the other side you've got you know
complete data Federation where every
tool knows how to talk to every other
tool and uh you know all data is
available everywhere all the time um and
most systems nowadays end up somewhere
in the middle um so you know what what
one of the goals of the brappy project
is to try and uh sort of push the the uh
breeding environments and and the
scientific environment into more of an
automated data sharing uh system um yeah
so uh like I said this is this is what a
lot of the systems looked like when I
first came on board in terms of
interoperability they were somewhat
interoperable but it was a lot of manual
effort um so uh yeah you can see um you
know know I would consider these two
applications interoperable you can share
data between them and you can you know
make them work together but it's kind of
a hassle you're you know
exporting um you know some sort of Excel
file some flat file from one system
maybe manipulating that uh manually
along the way so that it can be imported
into another system this works but it's
slow and error prone and and just sort
of ugly um
so uh yeah and then sort of talking
thinking about that talking about the
different types of uh
interoperability um again this is sort
of another dimension of this uh problem
uh talking about semantic
interoperability you know making sure
that the words and the data mean the
same thing that's really important for
humans and and scientists understand
each other there's a lot of work in that
area you know ontologies and um that
sort of thing um but then as you sort of
go down looking at syntactic and
protocol interoperability this is
looking at the structure of the data and
the protocol in which it's transferred
we as humans are pretty good at sort of
just figuring that out if you've got um
two pieces of data that are structured
slightly differently but they look the
same thing you they look like the same
thing as a human we can just sort of
figure that out that's a lot tougher
problem for uh software um um so that's
uh sort of one of the one of the areas
we're trying to address with the brappy
project um is getting some standards
around uh the syntax and the protocols
for uh moving data back and forth so it
can happen uh more
automatically okay um so what is the
breeding API the brappy project
um so brappy
is a standardized restful web service
API specification for communicating
breeding data and I'll jump into each
one of those terms just so we all have a
clear Baseline of what we're talking
about here um so starting with an API
what's an API um so uh all of us are
familiar with um use interacting with a
user interface when we're talking about
software um this might be uh you know a
graphical user interface or some command
line or or whatever but it's how you as
a person as a user interact with a piece
of software give it data receive data
back give it commands that sort of thing
an API is exactly the
same uh set of functionality but
designed to be from um one system to
another one piece of software to another
um so you know the one piece of software
can issue commands to another send data
retrieve data um all
programmatically uh through through an
API but it does exactly you know exactly
the same set of uh tools and
interactions that you might need uh for
a user
interface um yeah next we'll talk about
uh web services web services pretty
straightforward it's a service available
on a web
um so uh yeah generally speaking um web
services sort of take this this form in
the the cartoon on the right here um
you've got uh some uh service consumer
often called a client you've got a
service provider often called a server
um and you're building a request sending
the request across some Network um to
the service provider provider service
provider choose on that request and
spits out some response that goes back
uh to the to the service consumer so um
this this this typically with web
services not always but typically with
web services you'll have this Loop of
communication
um the the request response Loop uh for
for every interaction between the two
the two
systems
um and yeah rest restfulness so uh rest
stands for representational State
transfer don't need to worry about
remembering that everyone just calls it
rest um but it is a flavor of web
service um there are a couple of
different flavors of web service but
rest is by far uh you know the the most
popular right now um and uh rest is
built on um the well-known HTP standards
um so all the
same uh underlying functionality and
protocols that you use to browse the web
every day um rest just builds right on
top of that but instead of passing web
pages back and forth it's passing data
back and forth um and typically that
data is represented as uh Json and Json
data structures um it doesn't have to be
but when we're talking about brappy Ry
defines everything in terms of Json so
um that's uh that's what we'll be
talking about going forward um so that's
sort of the the the technical part of
the um brappy
definition this is the really important
part that I I try to
emphasize um on on every talk that I
give
um brappy is a standardized
specification um so uh it's a defined
set of um
um standard data models and uh
structures for communicating this sort
of data um that standard was uh is
defined and maintained by the community
that uses it um and uh at its core rappy
is a technical specification um
so that's that's a really important
piece to understand and something that I
used to get you know back in 2017 when I
was first taking on this uh people were
asking me like oh give me give me the
the tool give me a link to download
brappy so I can be brappy compliant I
was like it doesn't work like that were
just we're just looking at a
specification a set of technical
documents that outline what the standard
is it's up to you to go you know
implement it in your own system in your
own tool connect it in you know whatever
way you develop your soft software um
and so I I try to make this point uh
really strongly every presentation I get
to uh you know get the get the right
message across about what brappy is now
that said there is as Kelly mentioned a
large community around Bry there are
tools to build that are already built to
help implement the specification there
are lots of tools available you know for
um reading and writing and interacting
with the specification already so you
don't have to start from scratch but
this is this is sort of the key the core
the core component of rppi is just this
technical
Spectrum um yeah so if we look at the uh
specification as a whole uh this is a
little bit difficult to see on the
slides I think maybe the one on the left
is a little clear to see but um yeah so
this uh is a
highlevel uh picture of um all the
different cont Concepts that grappy
supports the different domains um we
broke it up into these four different
modules uh core which mostly talks about
um trial and study management uh
germplasm talks about everything
germplasm genotyping everything
genotyping and phenotyping everything
phenotyping um we broke it up into these
four modules purely for organizational
sake they all interact the same way all
these different uh
objects you know interact with each
other you can see the different
connections across the different modules
but it was a lot easier to keep things
organized and keep myself sane when I'm
looking for stuff within the
specification um and yeah you can see
the the variety of different topics and
and Concepts each one of these Concepts
listed up here um has a full set of
metadata associated with it you know
it's all part of the specification um
and you know I'll I'll emphasize this at
the
end on ry. org our website you can go
look the full specification and dive
down into each one of these elements to
see sort of the full set of metadata um
buried in each one of
them okay
so roughly how does this work um so yeah
we we talked about that request response
Loop uh ear for sort of a generic web
service um this is uh sort of a typical
picture of what you might find for um
two applications interacting via brappy
um and I have bolded here a couple of
different sections so the these two
application Stacks applications are
typically built in layers um so uh
you've got the the client application
which has you know maybe some user
interface that's that you're interacting
with um some controller and then these
these two bolded sections here's the
request Builder and the response Handler
um these two pieces are responsible for
taking the internal data structures of
the client application and mapping them
to the brappy specification version um
so whatever you use internally you keep
using that internally for your own stuff
but as soon as you're trying to send a
request out you need to map it transform
it into the brappy
structure send out that request with the
HTTP
service um that's going to hit the the
API layer of the service application of
the server side application um and be
consumed and then again we've got this
object mapping layer which is
responsible for doing the reverse taking
the the brappy object that it's received
in Json and convert in it mapping it to
whatever they use internally for their
own data structure so these two
applications don't have to use the same
types of data structures they don't have
to be written in the same programming
language um because the data is being
transferred using this uh standard you
know written in Json and and uh
transferred over
HTTP
um they they just need to have this
mapping layer to uh convert from the own
internal standard to the to the brappy
spec um and then again you know the
reverse happens on the response so the
server choose on the request does
something about it sends a response back
Maps it into
brappy sends the brappy response back
and the client response Handler knows
how to consume that read that as brappy
and turn it into its own internal
spec um so that's you know there are
lots of different use cases we'll talk
about later you know about how you can
put these sorts of things together and
what these two applications might look
like but this is sort of the general
flow excuse me of mapping um brappy data
structures back and
forth um okay so yeah let's talk about
why do we need brappy we're back to this
uh uh manual interoperability
cartoon have here um yeah we've already
sort of discussed this it's slow and uh
messy and you know uh potentially uh
insecure depending on you know what
you're where you're putting these
files um so let's change the picture a
little bit and try and automate this so
now we've got a lot less user
interaction no you know a lot less users
are touching the data to to manipulate
it in any way um we've got our brappy
layers um here and now just from the
second application our user can request
data from the first application it gets
automatically mapped transferred and
mapped again and now the the user can
interact with that data however it needs
to and we don't even need to store it
here you know in the in this previous
picture we're basically making a copy of
the data storing it somewhere else so
that we can manipulate it here we can
transfer the data it can live on the
first application and and stay there and
the user can use it interact with it
maybe store off a copy if they need to
but that's not required anymore or they
can uh you know just maybe they're just
trying to read the data maybe it's just
for reference maybe you know they just
need to perform some calculation and
then store that calculation whatever it
is um they don't need to make a copy of
it and uh it flows flows
automatically um so you can do this sort
of setup with any API um you know that
the API is it is itself what automates
this process um and this this data flow
between the two applications the extra
little piece that brappy brings is the
spe the standard the standard
specification so now um we can swap out
one application for another and it
should still work exactly the same
because all these applications are
talking the same language um uh using
using the brappy specification um and we
can swap it out for a different type of
application um you know it's some sort
of data warehouse in this case instead
of uh another um uh website whatever it
is because they're all talking the same
the same uh data structures talking the
same language um we can easily
interchange those
out um I should say in theory this
doesn't always work in practice but it's
a good starting
point um yeah so uh let's talk about
some of the uh appli ation and impacts
um that we've had already um there are a
number of solved use cases and the the
the ones I put up on the screen here
there're they're a bunch of solved use
cases but the ones I put up on the
screen here were specifically um these
were specifically chosen uh from our
first uh grant our first funding Grant
we set out um you know to try and solve
a a small set use cases with grappy and
say you know these are the ones we're
definitely going to tackle um and we
succeeded um so these These are the the
three or four that we uh you know
originally set out for and succeeded on
there are you know lots of other use
cases now and we'll look at that in in a
second but um these are some of the
basic ones
so uh first of all um looking at data
collection so uh did a lot of work with
the KSU field book uh folks um pheno
apps as they're they're now called um
and basically adding uh
rappy uh capabilities to the fieldbook
app so now uh people in the field they
can um you know just from from the app
they can download direct from whatever
database they're using uh get the field
layout and everything downloaded right
into their and and all the traits
they're working on downloaded right into
their app they go out collect whatever
data they need press the button and it
all gets pushed back up to the server um
this is sort of the primary example of
the the manual data transfer I was
talking about earlier where they they
used to have to download a file put it
on some cloud service or email it to
themselves bring it onto their phone
phone upload it into the app and then
reverse that process to get it back to
the server um so yeah that was a that
was a big win to be able to do that
automatically um via
brappy um this is another one in terms
of uh sample management managing samples
specifically going off to um some some
genotyping lab um and you know making
sure that the sample metadata uh remains
consistent between all the different uh
labs and applications that are involved
in this um we worked with a couple of
different genotyping Labs uh to make
sure we had the right uh standards that
would interact with their systems um
built these data structures so that um
from some sample management tool you
could send all the metadata
automatically along with your physical s
shipment of samples to whatever lab
they would have all the metadata um you
know exact copy of whatever you had and
then that uh copy of of sample metadata
could also go to your uh genotyping
database wherever you're storing your
final uh genotype results um you know
along with some some automated
functionalities to get the the results
from the lab to the database wherever
that might live um so that was that was
a big success um this is one that's uh
still being actively worked on and and
implemented right now
um the the basic idea being um
pulling uh data from from a number of
different data sources uh into some some
kind of uh analytics engine um run your
your models your calculations whatever
you're trying to do um and provide an
output so again just trying to avoid
moving physical files into some sort of
calculation engine um and have this be
an automated flow so when you've got uh
you know regular breeding processes that
you know you're going to run these same
calculations every year every month
whatever um you've got this automated
flow to just do it at a press of a
button pull the data in run your
analytics and present the the report um
like I said there's a couple of couple
of different projects actively working
on this right now um and and setting up
this this type of
functionality and finally the braps um
so braps uh I I had been working uh on
the brappy project for maybe six months
and uh Lucas Mueller um came running
into my
office and he he just stood in my
doorway and went we need PRS and then
ran
away and I said
what um but it it turned out to be a
really good idea once I caught him and
and had him explain um
so the the concept around BRS is there
little
self-contained uh applications that run
entirely on the brappy back
um and so someone can write a lot of
them are are written in JavaScript they
don't have to be but a lot of them are
little JavaScript web apps that you can
just plug into your own website um and
as long as you've got the um you know
the the brappy data sources implemented
to that the app requires um you have
this new functionality so yeah um uh
different um visualizations pedigree
viewers
um sort of the one buried there is a
um plot mapper you know over over a real
um
geolocation um so yeah the these these
were really cool and one of the other
cool things about this is it it touches
on sort of a a big data concept where um
instead of moving your data let your
data live where it is because it's
really big and a pain to move instead
bring your applications bring your
software to the data um and so this was
another you know we're not just sharing
data within the Rapid Community we're
actually sharing applications because
those are a lot easier to move and to
implement other places um so this was
this was a really cool uh concept that
that we've been developing and there
there are a number of PRS available now
and a few more that are being developed
by various members of the
community um yeah and I'll quickly touch
on you know the I mentioned there's a
lot more use cases um uh within the
community right now these are some of
them um there's a whole page on bie.org
that lists out the compatible software
that people have volunteered to register
there's still more that people haven't
put on there yet um but yeah we've
started building a list of all the
different compatible software packages
and applications that are brappy
compatible right now um so yeah
encourage you to go check that out on on
brappy it should be pretty easy to find
the the compatible software
page um and you know none of this would
be possible without the brappy community
so I'll I'll end on on sort of an
overview of the the brappy community
um uh we've got uh roughly
37 uh part partner organizations
registered partner organizations it's
really easy to become a partner
organization you send me the logo for
your organization and I put it on the
website and there you are you're
registered
um yeah roughly uh you know 200 to
um uh plant breeders software developers
data managers you know other expert
scientists in their field um all working
together building the software that's
that's compatible um helping build the
the standards you know we we really need
to come we we really needed to come
together as a community to decide on
what these standards were U make sure
that they're useful for everyone um
that's you know one of one of my rules
if someone comes to me uh with a new
idea for a new concept or or new piece
of metadata they want to add to the
standard I you know try and tease out of
them first is this going to be use
useful for you or is this going to be
useful for everyone else um and usually
if I can find two or three different
organizations that all agree that yes
this new piece would be useful then
we'll start working on adding it if it's
just one group saying oh we need this
thing in the spec then maybe we'll hold
off until until it becomes more
useful
um uh yeah we also have a a full
um uh Advisory Board six elected
officials from the uh from members of
the community uh make up that Advisory
Board um and uh they're they're one of
the driving forces that sort of
represent the community um help me make
quick decisions on on you know building
out the spec um they're one of the
resources I go to when I'm you know you
know I'm not an expert in plant breeding
I'm a software guy so if there are
questions on the science of it or what
makes sense how to how to construct the
spec um they're generally the group that
I go to
first um this is a slide I like showing
uh just uh showing the the different
organizations that uh we've worked with
um Kelly wasn't joking when he said you
know traveling all over the world uh
visiting these different uh groups and
the the different science and different
software they're they're all producing
um it's yeah it's very exciting to see
it all on one uh global
map um and finally the the hackathons um
so one of
the
primary ways that this community gets
together and and stays together is
through hackathons we've run hackathons
about twice a year um post covid uh
we're doing uh one iners and one virtual
uh each
year um and yeah this this was you know
an opportunity for all of these folks to
get together talk in person um you know
build projects with each other you know
during that week the hackathons are
usually a week long um and we all get to
see each other in person and uh build
all these different tools together and
talk about the specification and come up
with new ideas um our most recent
inperson hack on was uh this past spring
in South Carolina um our most recent
hackathon at all was actually a virtual
one that just wrapped up at the end of
October
um it's tough to get group photos from
virtual hackathons though
um yeah and
um uh bunch of resources here um if
anyone's interested in learning more um
like I said you know all this is
available on ri.org
um and uh yeah there's a there's a
contact page you can join our mailing
list or our slack Channel um if you want
to get more involved um and I'll leave
it there if there are any
questions um that's a good question so
um generally speaking there needs to be
a mapping layer because we're usually
working with systems that already exist
and we're adding crappy to them so we
don't want to you know redesign their
whole storage system just to to make
them compatible so most of the time
we're talking about mapping and and uh
making things compatible um there are a
couple of projects um going on now
somewhat recent projects where people
are taking the brappy specification and
adapting it for uh a database schema
basically um and then in that way it's
it's a much more direct translation um
and so there are there are some of these
projects where you can like download the
um the the brappy schema database and
it'll spin up a full full database with
all the brappy compatibilities built
into it um but that you know again
that's starting a new database from
scratch which not everyone is interested
in doing so some of
both yeah so is
you can pretty much plug in whatever you
want um breed base and the breed Bas
crew they've been part of the project
since the beginning um and so um it's
sort of interesting that different
groups H you know have different
approaches to implementing brappy so uh
breed based what they opted for was you
know full implementation of the brappy
spec just get it all out there and and
ready other databases are saying you
know selecting well for this specific
use case we only need these five brappy
calls so those are the five we're going
to
implement um so you know it has pluses
and minuses um so breed base has a full
Suite of rappy end points but um some of
them haven't been tested yet some of
them just aren't used ever uh versus you
know um BMS uh has a more concrete set
that are well tested but it's a smaller
set of of endpoints um yeah and there's
there's a number of different databases
and and hopefully more adding as we as
we go
forward
um so a lot of Mo I would say most of
the time people have an existing
database they're working with and you
know that'll either be a database that
I've worked with before and so they have
some rappy compatibility already or
it'll be a new database and I'll try and
start working with them to to get them
the the compatibility um there have been
a couple of times where people have come
to me asking for recommendations for for
data and I try to stay very neutral um
you
know yeah no no no I I I try to stay
very neutral and I lay out sort of the
pluses and minuses of of each of the
systems that are within the community
you know trying to get a feel for what
they're working on and what would uh
what would best fit their their
situation so I I really try to stay very
neutral
there
personally
yeah yeah
yeah that's a great question um so first
would be come talk to me and see if I
can help out um I do have some spare
development time that I can uh you know
I can assist people getting started um
but I can't maintain every every system
um
uh
um they yeah they had they had the
resources and and yeah in particular um
so we we worked with um them and dart to
try and build the initial standard
together trying to make you know the the
standard that would work for both of
those systems and then you know expand
did as as other groups came on board um
and so that they got it just because
they were part you know they were they
were the guinea pigs to to help develop
this um it it shouldn't take too much
effort to become brappy compatible um
one of the biggest time syncs is the the
concept mapping which isn't you know a
technical activity that's you know
that's a sit down with a whiteboard and
and map Concepts um and map names you
know and terms um and that's definitely
something that I can help with and um so
yeah you know basically just sitting
down saying okay what does your system
look like what does brappy look like and
figure out what that is then actually
implementing that code is pretty
straightforward once you get a sense for
um what the mapping
is and uh T3 is breed based now right uh
they I don't know if it's being used
right now but there was some work in
breed base to actually connected up to
like cornal genotyping and and that so
so one half of that problem is solved
already so um there is one endpoint that
I ask everyone Implement and that's
called server info and basically that
tells people what what brappy endpoints
that they have implemented so if you you
know I I choked the first time you know
way back when I built my first test
brappy server to just sort of get a
handle on it I made a single server info
endpoint and said I don't serve any
other brappy end points and said look
I'm brappy compliant um so that's that's
like the the bare minimum um and then I
I I don't really want there to be a
course set because you know everyone's
got different needs everyone's using it
in in slightly different ways and
different use cases so um you know as
long as they've got that one end point
telling the rest of the world which ones
they they are compatible with and what
version they're compatible with and all
that sort of thing um I think that's
that's fine it's been fine so far
um uh and I I really try to uh you know
one one of the other questions people
come to me with is um uh which metadata
fields in the spec are required and
there are actually very few metadata
Fields within the specification that are
required from a brappy point of view
because each different use case is going
to require different fields so you know
most of those fields aren't required but
if you want to connect to fieldbook
field books got its own set of wrappy
fields that it reads from and so those
are going to be required um if you're
trying to connect to fieldbook that sort
of thing so that that flexibility has
worked well so
far
yeah specific question you know
anys experimental
Des that the search
function that's that's definitely one of
the search functions
um uh you know ask me or join our slack
and sort of ask the the community um you
know in general um the uh the
compatibility the compatible software
page has a search function in it um so
you know all the all the different and
this this
is something I'm actively pushing the
community towards is is getting their
software posted on there because I know
that there are tools and applications
that aren't on the website yet but I
just have to track people down and get
all the information I need to put them
on there um so actively working on that
to sort of expand that set um but yeah I
mean th those if you're just looking for
some tool to do something those are
going to be the first few places to look
um and then uh you know we might find a
tool that's similar or close and then
it's working with those developers or
you know whoever to to expand on
that any other questions yeah
star
yeah so um that's a good question so for
most of the
um the the end users uh who aren't
interested in in programming
um yeah they're you know they're they're
going to benefit most from the different
tools and capabilities um and sort of
the automated interoperability between
these different systems um so in theory
they shouldn't even know that brappy
exists or that that's happening in the
background
um uh one of the other ways though is um
I know you know this but uh khed is
working on a tool called qbm um which is
an r package that um basically takes the
the brappy end points and wraps them in
something that a breeder is more
familiar with or or you know our
developer is more familiar with um and
so the the qbm package is designed to be
able to basically get data automatically
into your R scripts whatever you're
trying to develop um without knowing all
the inner workings of grappy happening
on the in the background but still using
that to to get all that data from a
database um so yeah coule couple of
different options there in terms
of
um what what the users might know about
in terms of of
yeah
um so so yeah the it depends um there uh
we did you know put a lot of thought
into efficiency it's it's always a
balancing act between um you know making
data access efficient versus flexible um
so yeah you can uh get a you know a very
efficient data pipeline but not have
many options in terms of what you
actually want a query so we're always
trying to keep that balance of um making
the the rappy end points flexible but
also efficient and uh I think for the
most part we've hit it but um you know
different use cases may be easier or
harder depending on um what exactly
you're trying to do um you know we we
have uh you know as you know we've
worked with some some Enterprise systems
uh already um and you know trying to uh
get sort of larger scale data flows
going um and there there are some
techniques that have actually been added
to later versions of the spec to to make
that a little bit easier um and a little
bit more efficient in terms of how how
data is being transferred um and that's
something I'm always keeping an eye out
for is is fixing those sorts of problems
within the within the specification um
yeah I hope that answers your question
uh different versions of the
specification yeah um so we try to so
the basically there's each rappy version
is a has a major and a minor version so
um the current version of rppi is 2.1
right now try to keep backwards
compatibility maintained for all the
minor versions but major versions might
might lose some of that backwards
compatibility so
as long as someone's working in the
2.x range then all the end points should
be backwards compatible with each other
and and able to interact um but you know
as soon as you go back to one or or up
to three or whatever then you might lose
some of that compatibility so trying to
keep ranges of
compatibility um but still be able to
progress the the the
specification all right any other
questions
yes say
again um yeah so there's there's uh
metadata for defining locations and sort
of defining the the different
environment um we don't you know there
are plenty of uh apis and specification
or weather data already we didn't want
to reinvent that wheel so it's more
about identifying the location and the
type you know sort of the general type
of environment and then uh adding
connectors to you know say specific
weather data or or that sort of thing um
but yeah it is it is part of the
specification to Define this is where I
am this is the type General type of
environment that I'm dealing
with um so nothing in the spec
specifically for microbiomes yet um but
that's just because no one in the
community has approached me about adding
it um so you know this is this is how
New Concepts get added to grappy is uh
someone says I have a new use case but I
really need this microbiome data to be
part of it to to make it effective I
bring that to The Wider Community
somebody else goes oh yeah that would be
really useful and then you know we work
together to build out the the
specification and and add it to the spec
so it's a somewhat slow process to add
things to the actual
specification as a software engineer my
biggest concern is to make working
software um so if you've got a use case
that needs microbiome data you know that
uses brappy everywhere else but you need
this extra little piece just go add the
extra little piece we'll catch up with
the specification later and you'll have
a you know a slightly modified brappy
endpoint um for handling your data doing
whatever you need to do to talk to this
other system um and then you know that
in itself if you've got a working system
that has a
modified data structure that proves to
me that yes this data structure can work
for this use case and that's even more
proof for to add it to the rest of the
spec for the community so um yeah
nothing nothing about microbiomes yet
but yeah if you've got a use case
uh that the wider community be
interested in let me
know right yeah so um yeah like I said
we have a general sense of what the
environment is so we've you know got a
general soil type and sort of what's
going on um but nothing that specific
um uh and sort of depending on what
you're trying to do um there's there's a
pretty robust system for making obser
observations and tying that to
ontologies so you might you know have uh
some
observation um some some trait or some
variable defined as like the the soil
content or the M you know some piece of
the microbiome whatever um some trait
that you're measuring in the field uh
regularly those measurements could
definitely be recorded within the brappy
spec um but uh sort of not not def it
its own concept just as more
uh not fpic but just more observation
data um collected uh as part of a
study this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at
cornell.edu